multiplica uno y tres cuartos por siete
y un quinto simplifica tu respuesta y
escríbela como una fracción mixta ok
bien yo lo primero que haría sería
convertir estas fracciones mixtas a
fracciones impropias porque para mí es
muchísimo más fácil multiplicar las así
definitivamente pueden ustedes encontrar
una forma para multiplicar estos números
directamente sin tener que pasar por las
fracciones impropias pero para mí se me
hace muchísimo más sencillo usar su
forma en fracción impropia entonces
empecemos por convertirlas en fracciones
impropias 1 y 3 cuartos lo queremos
convertir a una fracción impropia
entonces empecemos por ver que esto es
nada más uno más tres cuartos
y ahora esto vamos a convertirlo en una
fracción que sea muy fácil de sumarle a
esta fracción así es que lo vamos a
convertir en cuatro cuartos y podemos
hacer eso porque 4 entre 4 es 1 y ya que
lo tenemos así pues ya simplemente es
una suma normal de fracciones o sea 4 +
3 entre 4 que es igual a 7 cuartos y
ahora vamos a convertir el 7 y un quinto
para que toma su forma como fracción
impropia ok hacemos lo mismo tenemos
aquí 7 más un quinto y este 7 está
multiplicando a un 1 de la forma
apropiada para que sea muy fácil de
sumar con este quinto
es multiplicarlo por cinco quintos y eso
que es igual pues el un quinto se va a
quedar exactamente igual pero por otro
lado aquí ya no es lo mismo que acá no o
sea aquí lo que tenemos cuando nos
estamos multiplicando un entero por una
fracción lo que tenemos que hacer es
multiplicar el entero por el numerador
no entonces lo que tenemos es siete por
cinco quintos muy bien 7 por 5 es 35 o
sea que tenemos 35 quintos y estamos
sumándole un quinto entonces nos queda
35 más un quintos que es igual a 36
puntos uno y tres cuartos es exactamente
igual que siete cuartos
siete y un quinto es exactamente igual
que 36 quintos entonces lo que nos está
pidiendo aquí es que multipliquemos
siete cuartos por 36 puntos ahora aquí
hay otra cosa muy importante 36 es
exactamente igual que 9 por 41 y aquí en
el denominador tenemos un 4 entonces lo
que podemos hacer es cancelar este 4 del
numerador con este 4 del denominador y
lo que nos va a quedar es 7 por 9 entre
5 y 7 por 9 cuánto es 63 o sea nos
quedan 63 quintos
este es el resultado de la
multiplicación que nos están pidiendo
pero nos están pidiendo que lo
simplifiquemos cosa que ya hicimos
cuando teníamos esta multiplicación no
lo teníamos como un resultado
simplificado si aquí pusiera yo un 4 y
expusiera yo otro 4 como lo teníamos
arriba entonces esta multiplicación no
estaría en su forma simplificada ok
tenemos que quitar todos
que tengan en común el numerador y el
denominador ahora la otra cosa que nos
falta para terminar con este ejercicio
es escribir el resultado como una
fracción mixta ok tenemos que escribir
esta fracción como un número mixto y
como hacemos eso pues hay que ver
cuántos enteros hay aquí y cuántos
enteros hay aquí pues tenemos que
dividir 63 entre 5 a cuánto nos da eso a
ver aquí en el 6 cabe por lo menos 15 no
entonces cinco por uno nos da cinco
restamos seis menos cinco nos queda uno
y bajamos el tres y ahora sí cuántos
cincos que venden todo el trece
puedes caben 25 y entonces 2 por 5 nos
da 10 tenemos que restar y como residuo
nos queda el 3 y nos queda finalmente 12
enteros
tres quintos y esta es la forma en
fracción mixta de uno y tres cuartos por
siete y un quinto